allora questa gara andando adesso tumide
riaccompagnare in questo questo è nando
nando
non mi ha caricato l'avamposto dovreste
vedere come lo sto vedendo vi prego
poligono rosso boliviano fa spesso ma
che ca non era mai successo non ti prego
se mi faro che sbaglia che credo non
possa sbarcare sbarchi rischi mette
gràcia no cacchio sono sbarcato si deve
debuttare sia bello l'aggiornamento
nuovo
pronta cannoni loro sono pronto a un
morto cazzo te la vai a spararle a
sparargli e lorenzo ceo colpiti però un
chilometro so che sono talmente
lontanissimo però si guarda e molestava
fa piagne li stiamo proprio a fabiani
hey man che cattiveria pacchi news sola
c'è uno quest'anno un sacco di tesori in
mezzo all'acqua la scialuppa cintura
eccolo lo ha visto litighiamo sulle vene
non devono sali a bordo acqua stasera
questa qua a fianco ma ci piace via le
scalette o ce l'abbiamo a bordo thomas
sfaccettato ragazzi del celano
ok sono morti due è la causa da qua
una volta colpito colpito mi butto giù
ok ori colpito e ucciso o grigi ragazzi
ok andiamo a vendere tutto hey man
avorio figli
mamma mia questo evento è stato prima di
tesori come io nordic sì sì che abbiamo
lascia luchetta qua adesso possiamo fare
un sacco di gara provando active seven
seas hanno anche della roba su monaco
poi prendiamo tutto ma ci hanno fatto
non vendere tutto è perché non fai in
tempo per davanti a ruba la madonna
ragazzi incredibile poi il titolo
abbiamo [ __ ] della roba di lussi le
abbiamo percolati clicca qua i capi clan
e guarda ai russi che piangono clicca
qui italia russia perché l'avevo già
fatto sul vaticano questi stoccaggio
perché io ho già fatto a sta roba sul
numero che cli ge contro i francesi
contro i prossimi caputi ne sta già
preparando allarmare la guglia più
grande quando siamo morti e gli dèi nube
non rispondevano più leggerne a questo
sempre che le gemme che possano ridare a
tutti io sto bene a caso perché frenesia
adesso o fucking un accento proprio
prettamente questo posso dirlo mi fanno
venire nei pantaloni ci tengo
cerca il dipinto della lucertola
infinita dovrebbero una ragazza bruno
per ora piuttosto un tesoro tra quello
che hanno fatto a tutto casa
cacchio lo sapete che non ci abbiamo la
luce verde uno dei mori costò scheletro
qua
venite un attimo giusto perché vengo io
vengo io lo faccio io che mi piace stato
niente lo dobbiamo illuminare con la
luce verde cacchio sto morin malissimo a
ecco l'aspetto arte lo illumina entra un
pasto teschio patrimonio cosette schio
fighissimo vale dire il patrimonio
antico mi coccodè che cacchio stai
facendo
la nave avvistata la vedo abbiamo
ragazzi
concludiamo questo episodio come si deve
ragazzi fanno i pirati quelli serie
abbiamo un sacco di tesori adesso perché
questa misura sia presente sacco media
anche con code morta vediamo se
se riusciamo a farci valere porto
demonio speriamo di sì
intanto coccodè mai reso avere un
occhiata non verrà dato alla squadra
cos'è allora con un po di lavori quindi
al padre
si stava centrali mourinho ha un
bellissimo con un sacco di lag ma ci sta
vero
allora questo è un rischio grande
prendeva percorrere ragazzi
noi viviamo nel rischio come stiamo
messi io stessa l'incarico allora
cerchiamo di passare un dito viene a
destra questi esodi agostana persona
parti sono partito da allora ha girato a
destra non ha cercate mette in scia
vedevano seguici devono assolutamente
eseguiti è invece ci tornano
no no non ci vogliono incornata su tutto
pesa su tutte io io e ti aspetta che
cerco di rapida a 101 as titola perché
loro si schiantano ora che ci fai o quel
avventa vela tempo di avvento di
lamentele l'avvento della ventola
[Musica]
mentre oltre quella dietro si parla io
provo a dardo il bersaglio sui cannoni
di testa ma bersaglio per tuffarvi
contagio è male la rete bombette
infiammabili
no adesso davide siate via vieni cuore
in quanto i lanci maiolo a infiammabili
nel senso che dopo una brava e non è
però ciò con l'esplosivo spetta canale
sinistra modo viene stand a dovere stare
il cielo bersaglio perché loro la verità
che saluta l'italia arrivò agli
incendiari che non solo non ci piace che
si poteva fare nostra ma no ma no non
c'è l'angolo buttato sull'isola allora
vanno dietro ancora no esistono in
pubblico tutte le mele giu no in realtà
stanno muovendo st manco ora mi sparo
guarda che è rischiosa sta cosa
[Musica]
sotto la misura tiratemi sulla maestra
che stamattina ha visto la 21 ma dove mi
ha fatto entrare da fatto ci arrivano
ancora o morto no ma fatto g commenta
saltò giù piace affatto ci ha fatto ci
ha fatto tutti e tre senzatetto cacchio
è salito è andata signori signor tv ma
in seguito
[Musica]
basta
no
[Musica]